First login, the first screen that is visible, we have to make it a dashboard.
So the first section will be student module, SAS module.
On the left side, you have student.
As soon as you click on it, all the reports and information related to the student will be shown to you.
So the first one is student list.
What do you think of student list?
List of all students present in our list.
Can we export the data from here?
Any guesses?
You can speak.
Interactive session will be clear to you.
Now tell me whatever you think.
Student list is basically the data of the student.
We can see the student in our institute, class list, etc.
As soon as we click on the student list, the data of all the students present in the institute will be shown.
You can scroll down and see the total number of students present in the institute in this session.
Then here, item bar page.
The more you increase it, the more data you will show on the screen.
If I increase it to 25, then I will have 25 students' data on the screen.
So this is your screen where the data of the student is shown.
Now you have the option of filter.
This filter option is available to you most of the time.
Filter means you have to search the data according to yourself.
For example, I want to see the data of a particular class.
For example, I want to see the data of a nursery class.
I want to see the data of only one section of the nursery class.
If I don't want to use all these categories, then I can unselect them and filter them.
If I filter, then all the students of the nursery class have been shown.
Now what I have to do in this, if I have a specific category in the filter, general 134A, then our fee category is there.
You must have seen that in the case of schools, there are students who are in the general category.
Have you ever heard of RTE 134A?
Have you ever heard of RTE 134A category?
Not me, I haven't.
In the case of schools, some students are given specific comments for which fees are not paid.
So these categories are made.
So this is the fee category.
Its impact is on the fees.
What fees are going to be paid?
We have old and new for the students.
So you must understand that the students are the new students for this session or the old students.
For example, I want the data of only one old student in the A section of the nursery class.
So if I filter like this, then there are no old students here.
If I filter like this, then there are no new students here.
Now you have a list of all the students on the screen.
In case you want to view the details of the student, then how can I do that?
There is an action here.
In the action, click view.
As soon as you click view, the detail of the student will be opened.
My first student is opened.
The name of the student.
If I want, I can also update the profile picture.
I have the same option to update.
Thereafter, here are the details of the student.
If I want to change something, here are some other details.
Here are the basic details of the student.
For example, his personal details.
This is the student field.
Do you remember the fields that you were adding in the entity setup?
The default fields that you are setting are these default fields.
From there, for example, there is a gender field.
Instead of gender, you have to put some other name here.
You can change the display name from there.
Those fields are all coming here.
Some of them are blank.
For example, you have to put personal details of the student.
In every option, there is an edit option.
If I want to change something in this section, I will edit it here.
Then here is the number that I want to put.
I will save it and it will be saved.
In this way, you can edit any detail.
His phone number, his parent details, anything.
These were the personal details of the student.
His parent details.
Then there is the wickle details.
Wickle details means which wickle is assigned to the student.
Here are the wickle details.
For example, there is a student.
He can be transported to the institute.
How can we assign the transport to the student?
That is your wickle details.
For example,
I want to assign a transport.
I click on assign route.
A pop-up window opens.
Whatever you have imported in the system, wickle, routes,
you will select from here.
Whatever amount you have put by default,
you have to put it in this installment.
You have to put the amount in April, May, June.
You can assign it from here.
Basically, wickle details of the student are there.
Then if the student wants to get a hostel,
then the hostel details will be there.
The subject details will be there.
The subject assigned will be there.
So this is the UI.
This is your page.
The complete details of the student will be there.
Whether it is your fee,
or the subject details.
Ma'am, basically, this whole display is called SIS.
Yes.
Actually, there is a lot more in SIS.
It is not just SIS.
This is not student list.
This is all in SIS.
This is the complete.
It has all the reports.
Student list means,
how can you see the student,
how can you edit the student's details.
What is the fee, what is the subject,
what is the concession,
how much has changed,
you can see all that from here.
If you want to edit something,
you have to click on edit,
so that it gets enabled to edit.
and then save it.
Other than that, you have documents.
You can have student's documents.
For example, his Aadhaar card,
his admit card,
his father, mother's pictures, photographs,
anything.
You have documents.
Here you have the option,
you can also upload student's documents.
You can view them.
For example, the student I opened,
his photo is already uploaded in his document.
You can view it from here.
The same is uploaded by his father and mother.
You can view that.
In case you want to replace it,
here you have the option to upload again.
You can upload the information
that you don't have from here.
These were your documents.
In the same way,
if you go back to student list,
you will go back to student list.
Then we have an option,
active inactive.
What do you think will happen with active inactive?
What does it mean?
The student will be here for 2-3 months.
After that, he is not there.
It happens many times in this case.
At the institute.
He did not pay the fee.
Now, his admission is cancelled.
There is no reason, but he is not present in the institute.
So in that case,
the student is inactive.
In this session,
the student exists.
So he is active.
If not, then he will be inactive.
to get that admission number primary that's a student who searched there after a roll
number filled up with roll number or like a sign gonna be set up a ideas to get student
name map.
Can you tell me student that the real basic date of birth, you know, to get out of the
time.
I got up to pink line filled required.
It means more details.
For example, father qualification, mother qualification.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, yeah.
you have to be open to give it up for the transfer to sign connect we hostile we concession
to scale it up. They have to be correct. If you don't want to do anything, you can close
the way. I'm going to search here. The one I added to the student. The one I added to
the student is the one with the name one, two, three, four, five, six.
Apart from this, you have Excel upload. You can also use the bulk of the Excel upload.
The first option is add student.
Here you can add a student in bulk.
Sample Excel.
You can download this sample Excel and add data to it.
I'll show you sample Excel.
Yeah, please.
Basically important.
Name, father name, mother name.
Sample Excel.
Mandatory data.
If you haven't filled this one, you can add it.
But if you haven't filled this one, you can add it.
You can add it from Excel.
You have to fill the same basic details.
Then we have after the student list.
Student list course wise.
Student list.
For example,
class one teacher.
Right.
Student list.
Class teacher.
Student.
Student list course wise.
No more.
New student.
Excel.
To PDF.
Then we have student certificates.
ID card.
You can search by option.
Suppose you have to search for a single student.
You can search by name.
Search by name.
By default.
You can use the same filter.
you can give this certificate to the student by entering the details.
By default, you have to enter the details.
You have to enter the details and save it from here.
You can print it. The data is saved.
Then you have the option to print and inactive.
When the student is being released, you can use both options at the same time.
Print and inactive the student.
For example, I will just print it and show you.
This is our print. You can set it.
Alright.
This is how our DC certificate is printed.
Keep it here.
From here, the institute can print the certificate.
We have a DC certificate and a student ledger.
This is for fee.
The tuition fee certificate is also for fee.
You will know the character certificate.
This is basically used in college cases.
Student ID card, admit card, appreciation certificate.
I will show you the ID card.
You can print different certificates from here.
This is the student ID card of the institute.
Student certificate.
Is there any option for bulk print?
For example, I have to print bulk.
I have selected many students to print bulk.
You can print bulk ID card.
I have selected 3 students.
This is the option for bulk print.
This is the character certificate.
This is the appreciation certificate.
This is the single student ID card.
Student feedback.
student master setup.
Student feedback type or student feedback category.
Student feedback type.
Positive feedback.
Institute.
Positive.
positive.
behavior.
basic.
Setup.
Student feedback type or feedback.
Student feedback.
Open click.
For example.
Student feedback.
Open.
For example.
Other teachers.
Open.
Student.
Yes.
Then.
Good.
Attachment.
notification.
student.
Student.
data.
student.
notification.
Disable.
feedback.
Student.
Feedback.
options.
queries.
No matter.
scholar ID.
student.
admission.
scholar ID.
student.
change.
repeat.
student.
for example.
admission.
scholar ID.
change.
manually.
student.
edit.
save.
student.
teacher.
update.
class.
section.
data.
update.
for example.
column.
edit.
when.
registration.
admission.
updated.
student.
update.
Okay.
student.
edit.
update.
student.
enrollment.
class.
edit.
for example.
student.
query.
basically.